[Music]
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and
this week we have chris jack of winners
on a wednesday
he's got 20 rent to rent deals he told
me it was 13 but actually we counted and
it's actually 20
and he's packaged and sold multiple
deals
he's full-time in property he's been
full-time in property now for 18
months and he's going from strength to
strength chris
welcome to winners on a wednesday thanks
for having me are you excited yeah
pumped up yeah
honestly we we've been like we've got
closer and closer over the last few
months
you you're now stepping into some bigger
deals yeah we've got uh
as the times progressed we've got
ourselves involved in a lot bigger deals
there's a few
uh developments we're looking into and
larger larger deal sourcing deals that
we've managed to be involved in
uh we're just waiting for some final uh
figures on that
ultimately but yeah it's gone from a
couple events of rents to
the bigger deals now because you came on
winners on a wednesday
last year and you had a couple rental
rents you just
i think you just gone full time in
property and you were doing okay
but now you you know not not only your
results but also your experience in
property you're a totally different
person really yeah well that came
through a lot from experience to be
honest because at the time when i'd met
you
on on the last when it's wednesday uh
i i did just quit my job with full-time
property
uh i'd just taken on a few uh three or
four deals at the same time
and it overwhelmed me at that point yeah
to a to a degree because
i didn't know for instance i didn't know
how i was going to pay for some of these
deals how i was going to be get the
refurbishment on it uh bills were still
going out because it's guaranteed rent
that all of it just overwhelmed me to an
extent and people sometimes like to know
you know samuel how are you students
getting on a year later yeah you know so
and you've you've been through ups and
downs you've had you've had you've had
the
you know you've had rent to rent that
we're making i've seen them that were
making
thousands of pounds profit a month for
the sunny bang pandemic cane you've
actually
just some of some of them you've had to
let go of so
to date them right now what's happening
so you've
i mean right now we're in one of your
yeah
this is one of the rental properties uh
right now we
i i systemized the rents went business
once i got to a point where
i'd reached over 10 properties and had
over 90 odd rooms
combined uh which which you you're
questioning now because you think it
should be more because yeah because you
told me that you had 13
no yeah 13 rental rents yeah but
actually like this property for instance
that we're in it's four flats
it's four flats yeah just because the
landlord happens to own all four
and you've got so you've got 13
landlords but actually properties you've
got 20.
yeah that's that's a good way to look at
it definitely i mean they are
individuals
individual flats so yes that was that
how much is this
is this block making you each month uh
this block itself
it was quite creative and how it was
structured because
in fact it was the people i spoke to on
the academy that enabled me to create a
better deal from this
uh the landlord did want quite a quite
an a large amount for it because he
knows the nice flats he knows what the
area is like
uh he knows what he could get however
i spoke to people on academy saying he
wants this they said why don't you try
approaching with this way
and they suggested uh lowering the low
in the price
but you do the furnishings because you
can offset the furnishings there
with on
on finance for instance if you wanted to
or lease them exactly so
it allowed me then to have a lower rent
right
i had to pay a little bit more up front
but it had a lower rent for a longer
period right so now we're taking about
1500 pounds a month
uh on this one deal alone uh and before
kobe we were renting the rooms like
weekends
to service accommodation mostly to the
football traffic which obviously it's
kind of gone dead now but
that was with that combined it would
have pulled in about two thousand
that's fantastic so so profit right now
profit you're making about what fifteen
hundred to two thousand a month
a steady fifteen on this one yeah
fantastic and you know what i like about
you chris
i've watched your journey over the last
sort of 18 months and
you've been hit sometimes but you've
you're a man of integrity
and i mean we've been running one of
your hmo properties
you packaged and sourced it it turned
out to be such a good deal i'm saying
why don't you just keep it for yourself
and you say no i had an agreement
yeah and the fact that you were a
principal man you know i had an
agreement
same story you charge you've charged
fees sometimes like project management
fees and then you thought
my goodness this is a this is a bit more
work than i thought i should have
charged more
but you always follow through with what
you say you're going to do it's to me
people kind of can't people can't look
at property and try and get the quick
buck for to me
it's it's the long but it's it's the
long game it's the it's the
relationships you build
uh so for me i i not necessarily want to
take the maximum
i can straight away it doesn't have to
be because you can just
build a reputation they'll come back for
repeat business
and it's it's better for yourself and
the company for it and for them
yeah longer down the line and our
property director ben mcshake and janga
you know he's often said oh i've got
this great opportunity i'm looking at
i'll say where did it come from it came
from chris yeah
so so the thing is as much as you say
the academy's helped you and this person
and that person from the academy
you know you're the kind of person that
you come as an asset you know you come
and you bring a lot of value everywhere
you go
thank you so i really i'm really
grateful for the support and also just
the value
you're the kind of guy that will sit
with people have a coffee that's why i
want you on this interview because i'm
saying
everyone wants to pick your brain and
what you've done because you've achieved
so much it's like come back on winners
on a wednesday
share the story share the ups and downs
what's been the hardest point because i
know you have had some down times what's
been the most challenging
um thing that's happened over the last
18 months of this journey
er the most challenging there's two that
kind of sticks to mind
two that come to mind so let's say the
first one was
what can lead on to initially last year
when i came on the interview with
yourself
i take on too much what i didn't know
what to do how to do anything
uh but from that and finding out finding
the solutions
to the problems i had back then allowed
me to progress
as a com as a business and for myself
because then
you kind of can just get overwhelmed and
just think i can't do this it's not
going to happen i'm ruined but
if you just stop what's the solution
what's the problem what's the solution
like next what's the solution find that
so that was the biggest one i found that
affected me
and it made me grow and so i could be a
bit more calmer
in this lot of situations and at the
moment the biggest issue i think
everyone's experience is covered
yeah during the summer time you were we
were speaking quite a bit because we
were trying to get these
interviews but there was just too much
going on there was too much going on we
had the project
we were refurbing they were deal
sourcing there was issues going through
with steel was dropping out
there was tenants leaving the properties
so when you're doing a rent to rent an
empty bed
is profit loss so you need to be on top
of the game yeah so as much as we
systemized the rent to rent business had
a property manager and a lessons manager
in
which allowed me to set up the deal
sourcing company i had to
put that on ice a little bit to go back
into the rent to rent to try and
get uh the occupation occupation
back up sure and i think that's it's
really interesting what you said there
because
and looking at your journey you started
off with rent to rent and deal sourcing
you you've killed it to be fair and i
know you've had your challenges but
you've killed it
um now you're moving on to bigger deals
and development deals
that's the transition that i recommend
people to do i mean to go full time in
property
you went full-time in property real
quick you were full-time property before
you'd even done
most of the training i didn't even i
didn't understand the academy
no i hadn't said i did the did the dfv
and i just thought you know what this is
it for me i'd like to say i
had the company set up and i knew i had
them a sort of person who
will just keep going to make something
successful quit your job
in faith almost it was in faith yeah
that it was gonna work yeah but
and then you joined the academy and then
luckily you had you did have support
because i tell you what
do you think that if you were completely
alone in property and
with all the crap that can happen i mean
some people just couldn't cope with that
i i'll be honest it's uh i am a very
strong-minded person i've 13 years in
the military before that and i'm quite
confident in my own abilities and myself
as a
as an individual but there was a time
last year like i say when i had all
those problems
i shut down i broke down it was a mental
sweep but
relying on the people around you the
friends that you make it was it was a
someone i met at a pin meeting in my
local area yeah who
who i relied on almost to pull me back
into
you know normality thinking well it's
not an issue it's not an issue just go
over it
so this the support and the network
that's around especially with the
academy
uh because now uh co-sourcing co-source
is my business partner is patrick welsh
from the academy who i met
who we're doing deal sourcing with
together there's all sorts of groups of
people who have
i'm involved with yeah and all that came
about from the academy
and i think as well when you pay for the
academy training or any training
certainly with myself you're not just
paying for information you're paying for
implementation support and
environment knowledge network friends
and i think that's
for me that's vitally important that was
the biggest
push that was my biggest reason for
doing it and i think that is the biggest
thing i've taken from it as well
the the network is everything for me so
you've not you've been doing rent to
rent and deal sourcing which is fine
but that you've got so much more wealth
experience than that because i mean
we've just been to one of your brr hmos
i guess because you've been packaging
and selling deals but you've also been
managing the refurbs and stuff
your knowledge now when it comes to
things like brr finance development hmos
is just like through the roof yeah it's
growing all the time
i mean every every deal that you don't
necessarily get over the line
you learn something from it and then you
bring it to the next one and you're
always getting closer and then every
time you get
something ticked off you move on to the
next one so the natural progression for
me with my five year plan was to do rent
to rent for two years
and then move on to purchasing my own
and
developments etc yeah uh i managed to do
to systemize the events went business a
lot quicker so in the meantime
i'd set up the deal sourcing company as
well so with this
that side of things has pushed me on my
experience
exponentially really yeah how do you how
do you
go about deal sourcing so do you find
the deal first the investor first how do
you sell it what's the process ah
chicken and the egg
there's a chicken egg it's it's a weird
one because
it's it's the one question that i was
constantly asking myself and asking
everybody
and now that i'm on the other side of
the fence people are asking me uh
it's one of those ideally uh
personally i like to find the investor
to find the deal for them yeah
so you know what you're looking for and
then you can say to them like i found
this is exactly what you want
then you can promote that by saying i've
just found this for these everybody look
what what we can offer yeah however
sometimes you might just be a case of
i don't have the investor so if you're
good at finding deals then you can say
look
i found this you can co-source with
somebody and say and then you can get
recognized for
your ability to find the deal yeah so
it's it's is a chicken in the oven
average fee
to to to make on a deal that you've just
found and sold on
uh we average three we've sold we've
sold them for three thousand
we sold them to five thousand uh we have
the prop project management fees on top
of that as well if they wanted to do
that
so some of the investors that we're
working with they are based in dubai or
based in london
yeah uh are the ones who want to grow up
his words are i want to build a
portfolio aggressively
so there's people who just want to move
fast yeah so we've got the criteria for
these guys we're just ready to
to move on so what does an average day
look like in the life of a property
entrepreneur
as yourself like what does what does
your average day look like the average
day
uh you're kids right yes we've got our
married and that was a big reason for
why you did this
it was my why you know everyone finds
out what's your reason for doing
everything
yeah traveled a lot with all my jobs i
was always working away i was always
[Music]
abroad ten days at a time two days off
sort of thing or
working offshore uh enough was enough
you get married you have a kid you want
to
come home be home with the family so
that was my reason there's a lot of time
spent in hotels so
a lot of research into reading books
audiobooks youtube channels
you such as yourself yeah you're on it
now though other side the other side of
the screen
but that's what it all came from it was
making use of the time because i know
what i wanted to do
uh was was for the benefit of us in the
family i remember when you first signed
up for the academy
you told me it was it was it was for
your family you wanted to be absolutely
even tonight you were like
i've got another appointment a bit so i
need to go home like what's your
appointment and what is it
we're going to carve some pumpkins with
the family carve some pumpkins with the
family that's that but the thing is
though i think
you know that that's really important
you can you can spend your whole life
working crazy hours for somebody else
making somebody else rich and not living
your own life
but actually you decided enough enough
i'm going full time
and if it happens it's worked out well
but not to say i know you weren't crazy
hours you were you worked really hard
yeah i mean i don't really i don't
really see them as
as long as i probably work longer hours
now as a property entrepreneur
is investing because you're constantly
uh looking at dale's packaging
working on something on the business the
deal sourcing the social media
you're always doing something but it's i
don't see that as work though i don't
see them
you know i could say i work longer hours
but i don't see it at work
but when you love what you do and when
you're at home your laptop you can take
breaks
with your kids it's it's it's lifestyle
that's it it's endgame
it's you i don't mind putting 20 hours a
day in i don't mind doing the work now
because i know
where i'm going and what i'm trying to
achieve yeah it's just a matter of me
taking the right steps and what would be
your advice
to somebody watching this that's maybe
five years behind you
working crazy hours and and they're
thinking you know what i want to start
family i want to buy my time back
i want to get into property haven't
necessarily got lots of money maybe i'll
start ready to rent deal packaging
what were your best pieces of advice uh
look at yourself ricky and find out what
you want that's the key thing is
is is where do you want to be yeah
you're saying if it's five years ago
where do you want to be in five years
do you still want to be in the same job
same position or do you want to be
your own boss you're sitting at home uh
or doing what you want it might be in
you know
the pharaoh islands doesn't matter stop
stop finding out what that is that
passion
and then take knowledge take action
knowledge and action is the key things
here
one of the fundamental reasons that
pushed me or incentivized me to get
into this is there's nobody
who was you'd have to go to university
to become to get a degree and to be
qualified as professional
uh property investor you just it's about
taking action and learning along the way
there's so much information out there
yeah it's just
learn it and then implement it that's so
true get the knowledge
take the action and then persist yeah
you
you will oh it's the roller coaster yeah
the higher the high and the lows are low
yeah there will
there will be it's guaranteed there will
be lows you've had to adapt your whole
service accommodation market
because previously you were very much
catering to tourists am i right you're
saying
yeah we have a block of h2 departments
that's in the city centre
yeah um that was primarily uh
weekend go as football traffic or
stack dudes et cetera it was primarily
for tourists
we didn't we didn't really have any
money to friday bookings however with
that
just on the weekend bookings we're still
generating on the good months between
two to three thousand
profit a month uh kovid
wiped it completely yeah cancelled every
booking we had
and i could say this was back in
february we had bookings taken up
between eight and ten thousand gross
up until september so we knew back then
we had that ready
gone the whole thing got wiped off
terrible so we've had some really
so destroying ice it was it was
it was it was hurt yeah in the chest
when you banked that money because it
was not
physically banked it but in your mind
you're like it's coming yeah it's booked
and then suddenly
you can't even you can't even book
through airbnb so what did you do who's
your market now
so we've changed we've changed the the
clientele to
contractors now yeah so we've had to
really push
to try and get them through marketing
campaigns facebook ads
instagram ads everything we can do to
try and get out there
even as far as visiting some of the
sites in the local area
just trying to promote the business yeah
trying to promote what we can offer
now liverpool itself is uh
it's got quite a lot on offer in terms
of essay service accommodation so
we've had to even look at bringing the
prices down to reflect this
uh so it's uh it's been a difficult time
yeah for sure but it's about knowing
your market knowing the price point
yeah i mean this this this property that
we're in didn't you say was it the last
one
he said we had contractors that signed
for like six months or something crazy
yeah this one this is contracted to here
this whole this whole deal was it was a
whole
fortuitous set of circumstances i mean
the deal came about uh a carpet fitter
who fit carpets for me one of my first
jobs a year ago we just got on really
well
i liked him here like me he did a few
more carpets for me he ended up trying
to buy a shop
in local area he was just passing by off
this place was getting refurbed by the
by the vendor and he just walked in to
see if he could sell carpets to them
and at the back of that he ended up
passing my details to the landlord
and then the landlord contacted me and
then we negotiate the deal on this
fantastic networking right that's it
yeah you don't know where it's going to
come from he's
since then we've created a good
friendship with this vendor as well uh
he's asked me to look at another
property of his
in the city center we've not been able
to agree on anything just yet
with that but again it's you don't know
where these leads are going to come from
another interesting thing is you know we
we say don't count your chickens until
they're hatched
yeah people might watch this and think
of you as red to red
deal packaging i know you've got some
crazy things in the pipeline which we
can't really talk about right now we
can't but
some potential seven figure deals
development
some crazy stuff going on you're also
working with some
you know pretty high net worth
individuals that are looking to do
business with you
you've got my team interested you know
my property team are saying oh chris
chap's doing this who stops doing that
so you know it's really exciting talk to
me a little bit without going to
specifics about what your future holds
and what what the next phase is going to
look like for you now you've become
financially independent from deal
packaging and rental rates yes
the next next phase for me is is to
really it's
to push on with the with the deal
selling and such where
with my business partner on that so i'm
patrick welsh
patrick welsh he's on the academy he's
we met on the academy
academy we kind of we just i was
at a level ahead of him in terms of the
rents of rent
yeah initially back then and he was
having the same problems so he reached
out to me and i was helping him yeah and
then we
actually just pulled it together what's
the name of your dinner sourcing company
i'll leave a link
uh nordic property solutions
nordicpropertysolutions.co.uk.com i'll
leave the links if anyone wants to get
deals from you or talk to you
i'll leave a link for that and i can i
can vouch for you as a person as well
because
you know you're a great guy yeah
appreciate that we do send out as
we do send out deals quite regularly we
have some we have some quite
uh fantastic deals recently uh
especially the
you came to view one of our properties
that we packaged and project managing
for one of our investors at the moment
yeah that's gonna be a crazy uh almost
all money out deal
for them and cash flowing uh over a
thousand pound net
incredible month for them so yeah
they're happy so it's just again repeat
repeat repeat
incredible so talk to me about the most
satisfying the most aha moment like oh
my gosh this was
you know for you because i know you've
had some down to talk about that at what
point did you think i'm
so glad i quit my job i'm so glad i got
into this
i don't know i don't think there's
anything that at the moment that stands
out as the
moments it's a collective uh
there's a collective bunch of situations
really mostly
again like family time yeah uh for
instance during the summer during the
covert
or even last summer should i say i was
just being able to go on like a
wednesday afternoon
take my boy to the beach just to do
something
what are you doing today i i can go and
go and play with you go and take it to
the park
it's those sort of things that i'm
thankful for that property
has allowed me the space the time and
capacity and obviously the financial
freedom that comes with that
and now it's just a case of making sure
that my ambitions is obviously
just keep going and going yeah that's
where my goal is to be
higher and higher that's right well i've
i've loved working with you
i'm super impressed i hope people get in
touch with you and i hope that
um you know people can people can join
adventure with you it makes me happy
seeing academy members doing business
together and
people who do together final words of
advice for someone watching this
next things they need to do in the next
couple weeks to really get started and
make this
begin to turn into a reality go set
yourself set yourself
goals in the business plan not
necessarily a business plan set yourself
goals um
realistic goals yeah achievable goals to
start with and then something that's
that's not realistic something that will
take a long time to get to but
it's a dream yeah but uh lay them out
into steps
start taking steps for me i wanted to
become financially free i wanted to quit
my job to do it
i decided to look into property found
property so many different strategies
you can do
narrowed in onto the rents of rent read
up on rent to rent
understood the ins and outs of events
event and then just implemented it and
take action
yeah so good i love what you said about
have a dream but then have
short-term stepping stones as well
everyone always has that i want to be
stinking rich and have a yacht and stuff
but how are you going to get there yeah
you need to you need to be progressive
yeah otherwise if you don't achieve it
some people it's going to be mentally
straining etc so
have something that you can just keep
taking off keep ticking off and you're
slowly
you're achieving your big goal you're
achieving it and it's getting closer and
closer when you quit your job what was
your job
i was a contractor then for installing
communication systems in
air traffic control tower so i was up
and down the country
everywhere is this more fun i enjoy it
it's not dirty anyway
folks i hope you enjoyed that interview
i think you can agree chris is an
absolutely fabulous guy so he deserves
every success that he's got if you'd
like to be sat with me on winners on a
wednesday
you're one of my success students you've
done some training you can apply by
going on winners on a wednesday.com
if you're not successful yet but you
want to be successful
then in the description check out some
free training that you can do
which will really get you started also
every single week i
interview people on my youtube channel
who are succeeding as a direct result of
our property investment training
and you can see a whole playlist up here
where you can watch literally over a
hundred interviews there's a lot
um also if you want to see chris jack's
first interview which was taken
around about a year ago you can check
that out right here
and please do me a massive favor smash
the like button and subscribe
you can do right here thanks so much see
you next time